[Music]
[Music]
alright guys it's another beautiful
morning I'm sitting here on the bridge
above my fishing spot getting a
bird's-eye view I can see one two carp
swimming around in that hole that's not
bad I'd love to catch one of those two
carp but I think that is better fishing
spot so I'm gonna drive around and try a
few different places and see if I can't
catch them carp with bread on the
surface so this bike past me in time we
were riding yesterday had a bunch of
carp really close to shore and I can see
a bunch there already
just like in a foot of water so I'm
gonna see if I can get them to rise to
some bread we got some ducks here so I
think this is gonna cause some problems
but I think you've it a go anyway it's
just some test pieces see if it's worth
rigging up my gear
oh they're gobbling that up but the
Ducks are a real problem the Ducks are
going crazy but the carp they're rising
the bread no problem
look at that nutria right down there
aviators caps the kamikazes were made
out of the tria they're brought to Japan
for that
[Music]
blew that another beautiful Japanese
common carp well guys I got time for one
more fish than I should be getting home
and I think that one more fish is right
here
oh here he goes he's gonna so take that
what area
I touched him so it counts and I got my
hook back that's a win okay maybe one
more fish just just one more fish oh
yeah
[Music]
oh well this really better be my last
car I gotta get going home I know my
wife ditches to do some sightseeing so
I'm gonna put this guy back but all this
has been so much fun well the guys know
some fun fishing but I've gotta head
home
start eating my peanut butter sandwich
though and the pigeons are attacking me
though time to fall flying in my face
they're watching me
it's another beautiful day and it's
hotter than all get-out but we are gonna
go to a socket we want to go see the
osaka castle just explore osaka a little
bit just to say we have and most
importantly i'm meeting a good friend of
mine either mr. subtle in osaka and
we're gonna take him and his family out
to dinner try that out
it's like KO baby like your french fries
Tommy's a bit of a foodie when it comes
to french fries every restaurant we've
been to they've brought out little kid
bowls and spoons and forks for Tommy
it's kind of it's kind of cute actually
there's some Kyoto version of Kobe beef
nice miso yakiniku dome nice and Tommy's
got some cut argue and french fries that
was probably the best thing I've ever
had
yeah yeah see see the picture of this
woman who's being attacked by a child
that's you
they both crippled end with child so
that's like double osaka second biggest
city in japan
tell me you were you see you say right
yes there you go is that nice that cool
[Music]
back there whoa holding at the depth of
that moat that is truly intimidating oh
you thought you saw a little fish attack
material that's cool
[Music]
so this is the main power the main cast
we're inside check it out
very very soon
do you need to take the elevator or
there's no line to take the stairs 100
degree heat everyone's taking the
elevator to the top of the castle nice
view
what does that boat down there and can
you go fishing that's what I want to
know yeah you have the giant carp right
there
oh yeah
[Music]
only got a samurai sword
I don't know hey buddy come on over here
[Music]
alright that was pretty awesome Tommy
got his photo taken in the little
samurai costume it is hot and humid and
there's a weight on my shoulder hey
Tommy Tommy wait a minute wait a minute
yeah he didn't pee himself I wet his
pants not the other way around
very cool those are the skins see they
live in the ground like little bugs or
worms they turn into those things and
they crawl up the trees and then they
burst out of their own skin and they
become flying insects that make all
those noises wait he tell me where we
gonna go next
what awesome let's do it we just saw a
bunch of people dressed up in cosplay
writing duel cards down a six-lane
highway
Oh Sark is a fun town
yep there it is are you guys sweet for a
hedgehog head job cafe is full well
apparently it's a good business model
just check it out that's the hedgehog
cafe but they're all booked up for all
today so tough luck sorry you don't get
to do that really fun thing and instead
we have to do other really fun things
okay this part of osaka is crazy
electronics anime manga that seems to be
kind of the vibe over here so we're
gonna see if we can find a show kid you
know white peach server looks pretty
good that tastes like real peach does it
oh that's good he's like a mix between
sherbert and gelato that was really good
McDonald's delivery
yeah I gotta love Japan this store has
the unfortunate English name of love toy
it's just a toy store just a toy store
that's all of this should we try to win
a stuffed animal Tommy let's do it
[Music]
I'm gonna try
[Music]
[Applause]
Tommy do you want that Pikachu what see
don't worry you share it with Nathan
[Music]
yeah we got to get out of here before
dad makes for mistake
yeah so I've burned like 20 bucks in in
attempts on the game and then paid it 18
so I think at the end I paid exactly
what it would have cost to buy the thing
outright all right we find in our
gallery hopefully this gets mom what she
wants
yeah we don't trust us Tommy in historic
tivity fragile things in there buddy
it's not for little kids let's see what
Mama's good mine good let's buy it
Oh
the boxes are always pretty and Tommy's
out there you happy babe excellent how
do I got to say my job Tommy has taken
to making farting noises in the back of
taxis just yeah
[Music]
okay guys wha I'm in here oh no vodka
with my good friend mr. Sato also known
as tukya we go way back when I was
meeting him were in our 20s we were
missionaries in Kyushu together so first
time I've seen him in a long time Oh JA
uh he looks exactly the same because
he's Japanese and will never age you
know are we all gonna fit in there I
don't even know okay Tommy you're in the
middle Pretenders didn't check this
place out
they've got minion gym base that's cute
that's that's cute
there's a little bit of a wait here at
the restaurant Becca's feeder barking so
she's gonna sit down and wait and call
us when they're ready and we're gonna go
by like minion pajamas or something
[Music]
you know Hanwha
do you ever see the guy students occur
do you think your you want their okay
alright guys I got myself a new sweat
towel ok says victory always victory on
the other sweat towel belongs to the
hotel so I'm gonna have to give it back
here soon so you want to wear that now
oh yeah we got our Dragon Ball Z shirt
sweat towel hmm
I'm pretty excited to see what happens
it is crazy crowded in there
we've been waiting to get in because of
course the Japanese people are wonderful
and they appreciate a restaurant where
you can catch and fish for your own
dinner all of these fish in tanks here
and they rent to fishing poles and you
pay for bait and they're going to catch
it and then you they charge you based on
how you have it code okay so we're gonna
we're gonna see what happens here this
is this is gonna be pretty cool I'm
excited all right guys
this place is awesome all right I gotta
take your shoes off
this is neat boom baby alright alright
so what she's saying is you can't let
anything go
you have to eat and kill whatever you
can we can fish anywhere we want I want
a pink zebra alright that is a
good-looking baited hook right there
sumimasen
go see today doc he was talking I was
going for the big boy go for it yeah
these guys are not in the meeting room
okay these pink zebra look a little bit
worse for wear and they're not in the
mood for eating right now my guess is
they're contemplating their own
mortality so we're gonna try the pink
zebra in for a little bit that doesn't
work we're going Snagit
[Music]
all right come on over here
[Music]
see if you can snare one
but you do telling us get him underneath
them there we go
[ __ ] chapter I'll give this one time
you got a new chapter there you go oh
yeah we're totally snagging fish for
dinner this takes me back to growing up
in Alaska
[Music]
[Music]
oh good job buddy that is the big-time
me pagina Toyota they caught an Aussie
and cover them and this is what's left
over so they made it
this is just fun we're having a ball so
we've got a pork omelet here with a
salad and some ginger some people ginger
and we've got some pickled vegetables
all the different routes and different
different Japanese vegetables and this
is Salmons sushi that's Tommy's fish
that's he's a deep sea bream right there
that's sushi style top
[Music]
you tell me you like your sushi no you
honey you wanna eat some more
maybe good wait what do you think it
didn't taste fishy that doesn't doesn't
taste bad does it
alright you were gonna try some of this
this pink sea bream sushi here it didn't
give the sushi is not cold it was caught
and killed seconds ago I remember you
[Music]
[Music]
good sashimi style
[Music]
oh yeah pretty much yes
okay so they want to get some temp with
us so they're gonna try to catch fish
with this basket thing
[Music]
[Music]
tell me would you want a deep fried
shark oh they're gonna kind of tell you
with the shrimp this place is awesome I
could eat here every night fishing and
hey Tom watch this watch this but this
right here this one watch this go right
up against the wall like this Hibiki ho
see boy it's all we need Tommy let's go
back to the zero Taylor all right let's
go eat those up while being Tommy we're
fiddling around the little fish miss
Sato here caught herself a big ol
flounder congratulations
Messiah John here caught himself a big
old time I mean it's all I like the
flounder I like the flounder more than
the pink zebra have to it who she cuts
it what is this forever forever
Mandarin a is I sure what this is
Corphish Phish somebody just put mystery
template up on my table
that's good it's octopus radical honey
suckle
[Music]
you know
oh that was like the best onion ring of
every okay these are the little washy
fish we caught a little silver ones in
the basket so we're gonna try this out
and it's at moments like this I realize
I don't know where my child is
it's kinda like eating a herring a
little bit like a herring you got a lot
of little bones in it but whatever
they got snails and clams and food
geoducks and a shark look at that shark
well I think we ate three sea bream and
one flounder a couple of those little
silver fish some shrimp we caught and
another thing of a jiggy fish we caught
plus a lot of tempo a couple omelettes
some salad we packed this away I'm
curious to see what the bills gonna be
it's gonna be awesome it's gonna be
awesome
yeah me and Sato go way back way back we
were both missionaries in Kyushu
together
that could we're both 20 19 years ago
good to see him well guys that was
pretty awesome that was about 250 bucks
which all of us eating that much fresh
seafood is it too bad actually guys I've
got a belly full of fresh fish and we
have had a great time this is a great
chance to catch up with some good
friends and just have a ball you guys
want to take this out if you're ever in
Osaka
check out food akiti well we are fat and
happy and the Santo kazoku is being so
kind they are they are taking us back to
all the way back to Kyoto so they're on
a road trip of kindness here and good
friends here good friends so any rate we
fairly well rested from a late night of
partying we're gonna head back to Osaka
and to go to church with my friends and
then hang out a little bit this is our
last full day in Japan it is kind of sad
just when you're starting to get used
for the language and out of everything
works time to leave we're here at church
a little bit late but we're here alright
guys well we just finished up with
church and we're here with the Santo
family and we're gonna go back and party
at their place and right now I'm trying
to terrify their children even further
by telling them the story of the Kodiak
Island grizzly bear that wouldn't die
Kodiak kuma what you'll miss it okay
alright we're here at the sato family's
house it is eggplant zucchini finger
jiggy yeah so if you're in Japan one
thing you end up drinking a lot of is
movie cha it's an herbal tea made from
like roasted wheat or barley or
something like that it's one of those
things where most people don't like it
when they first try it but after you
drink in a bunch you really get into it
I love it but I've heard it described as
drinking the water out of an ashtray
that's been left out in the rain but
we're gonna give Tommy some see what he
thinks
tell me what do you think of the mucha
you like it I do it I don't
do you want some more muchas muchas
doesn't have a very strong taste it's
kind of a weak flavor at first but then
it has this kind of burnt aftertaste
that some people hate and some people
love and I like it and we're eating the
onigiri which is just a rice ball with
this one has some like fish and seaweed
flavor in it but you can put all sorts
of different things in it again so so
they're asking if Tommy wants some pizza
and he has a choice between the one with
shrimp and seafood on it and the one
without shrimp and seafood on it
guess which one Tommy chose yeah but
yeah Japanese Pizza is really fun it's
it's they've got like corn and squid and
seaweed and all sorts of weird things on
it which before you judge just remember
Americans put pineapple on their visa so
oh my goodness
look at this that's that was a much
younger man right there look at that
that doesn't even look like me
Okabe Oh so they asked if we wanted to
see their vegetable garden I'm like heck
yeah beautiful eggplant and this is taro
right
taro potato well yeah sure enough get it
right there
oh look at that oh this point I don't
know what it's called but they boil the
leaves and they make a juice out of it
look at this is the watermelon vine and
they got it grow up the vines growing up
this net here and then they've got the
melons here protected and then this is
cucumbers right here well there we go
we've got some fresh vegetables for
dinner here that's pretty cool well this
is a lovely Sunday meal here we've got
rice with canned tuna fish lettuce and
mayonnaise got fresh corn deep-fried
eggplant here maybe a super student and
this cool fruit punch made out of the
leaves of a plant I've never heard of or
seen oh not too bad huh how you like a
big very good loser this is a beautiful
meal Jose are you are you taking that
corny challenge come here
I bet you were having fun
have you got the desire Liza I'm gonna
do the keep igloos bad yeah she omit
Texas this is one of the best nights of
the whole trap it is being able to hang
out the sato family and see takia again
yeah you know I haven't seen him in 20
years and you know that was just awesome
I was just awesome had a great time but
we have absolutely trashed this place so
we've got to get cleaned up and packed
and get ready to go and if I'm lucky and
I can get everything done tonight maybe
just maybe I can take Tommy fishing one
more time tomorrow morning but we better
get going if that's gonna even be close
to a possibility so I'm gonna put up the
camera and I'm gonna get this guy to bed
I'll see you guys in the morning
thanks for watching and we hope you
enjoyed this video check out this sneak
peek of the next installment of the 2018
World Tour if you like this video log
series don't forget to click the
playlist link in the video description
below thanks for watching if you want to
see more great videos from the outdoor
boys YouTube channel don't forget to
click subscribe we put out new videos
every Saturday morning